Je crois en la perfectibilité des
êtres humains en tant que cercle, nous pouvons enfin
réaliser notre potentiel lorsque nous sommes au
meilleur de nous-mêmes, il n'y a pas de problème que
nous ne pouvons pas résoudre, nous pouvons guérir n'importe quelle maladie
et nous pouvons et avons faim imaginer les
implications pour les droits de l'homme.  les possibilités
sont infinies votre paiement c'était pour 78
13 et Raziel était pour 78 31 merci vous
avez eu le travail au cercle bien prendre
un verre passer un bon moment et rester
excité nous sommes au cercle et je suis
comment ça va  toi Jared ici nous allons faire une
formation mon premier art il m'a fallu une semaine
pour maîtriser crois moi tu vas
bien elle vient me rendre visite au travail tu
pourrais penser que j'étais là pour nettoyer les
toilettes tout le monde aime vraiment  vous vos
travaux ont été exemplaires avec de forts saignements mais
votre absence à plusieurs avec eux désolé
mon père a eu un épisode et j'ai
aidé à la maison ce n'est pas lié à l'intérieur
alors j'ai examiné la
situation de vos parents et j'ai une idée alors nous le
pensons  aurait du sens où ils spo  ke au
plan de santé de Columbus Circle Je veux
voir à quel point ils apprécient ce que vous avez fait
pour ma famille maintenant vous êtes une partie importante
du cercle nous nous soucions de tous ceux que
vous aimez Mays n'est avec nous que
depuis quelques mois mais elle  a fait toute
une impression,
alors pensez-vous que vous vous comportez mieux ou
moins bien lorsque vous êtes surveillé,
nous avons des caméras en place partout dans le
monde en ce moment,
nous avions l'habitude de partir à l'aventure, nous avions l'habitude de
nous amuser et de voir des choses et maintenant tout est
filtré  à travers cela, cela
vous va vraiment bien
[Musique]
Je n'ai pas créé ce n'est pas ce que j'avais
en tête
dans le cercle dont ils ont besoin pour changer
tout ce qui est
enregistré en cours de diffusion analogique restauré
ici
vous obtenez cependant ils disent, peu importe comment
ça s'appelle
[Musique  ]
savoir c'est bien
tout savoir
[Musique]
donc moi est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose que tu veux nous dire
toi